hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem car fleet i
think a lot of people don't end up
solving this problem but i think it's a
very good problem and interesting
problem to solve so we're given n cars
that are traveling along the same road
it has one lane the road has only a
single lane and this is important for
the rest of the problem all the cars are
traveling towards some destination which
is at some target position right and
every car that we're given has a
position
and it has a speed associated with it
and remember they're all traveling in
the same direction towards the target
and the position and speed are given in
their own arrays so there's two separate
arrays given for b for each of these and
the important thing is that a car can
never pass another car that's because we
have one lane in the road right so
imagine we have two cars like these you
know this one's traveling and then this
one's traveling right let's say this
one's traveling at 10 miles per hour and
the other one is traveling 20 miles per
hour of course the faster one is
eventually gonna catch up to the slower
one but since they're in the same road
even when they do catch up that faster
one uh is just going to be traveling
right next to the slower one right so
the slower one was traveling at 10 once
the fast one catches up its speed is
going to be reduced to 10 because it
can't pass the one that's ahead of it so
once cars are basically traveling right
next to each other that is called a car
fleet and
and by the way if these cars are right
next to each other they're basically
assumed to have the same exact position
even though technically one is behind
the other one they still are considered
to have the same position uh that's what
they mentioned right here and they also
mentioned a car fleet is just some
non-empty set of cars that are basically
at the same position traveling at the
same speed and by the way even a single
car can be considered a car fleet so and
the last edge case you might be
wondering is if what if a car catches up
right at the moment that they both
arrive at the destination point because
remember once they arrive at the
destination they're going to stop so
what if a car catches up exactly at the
destination well they're considered a
car fleet and what we want to do
is determine the total number of car
fleets that will arrive at the
destination so you know in this case for
example this example problem we're given
five cars right so initially we have
five car fleets but when they actually
arrive at the destination which in this
case is at position 12 then they are
going to be reduced down to three car
fleets okay so now let's try to figure
out how we can actually solve this
problem and let's take a look at our own
example so here you can see i'm
basically combining the two arrays that
they give us i know they give us a
separate array for position and speed
but i'm just going to combine it into an
array of pairs so this pair represents
uh you know the first is the position
next is the speed so this is at position
three with speed three this is at
position five with speed two this is at
position seven with speed one
and our target in this case is ten so
i'm gonna actually explain this problem
in a way that you might not expect
because when you actually think about
what these cars are they're literally
just a system of linear equations right
we have the time on one axis
and we have the position on another axis
right and if we take a single example
such as this one right it starts at
position three so position three is over
here on the chart and it has a speed of
three what does the speed mean it means
that the slope is going to be three
right so every unit of time that passes
it will be in
three positions ahead right so in one
second it'll be at position six in two
seconds it'll be at position nine excuse
my kind of bad drawing here and then at
time 3 it'll be at position 12. so
basically it reaches it reaches the
destination 10 right remember 10 is our
destination it reaches it at let's say
two point something seconds right and we
could calculate that if we really want
to pretty easily it's just a linear
equation but i'm just drawing it out
just so you kind of get an idea of
what's going on here so now let's do
this one seven one and let's use a
different color just to kind of
illustrate things so it starts at
position seven and it has a slope of one
so each unit of time is just going to go
up one position so at time three is when
it's going to uh reach the destination
right so we can draw a
you know line like this one and what you
can already tell
from this drawing is these intersect
here right they intersect before they
reach the destination what does that
tell us that tells us that they are
going to become a car fleet this orange
one and the blue one right they
intersected over here before the orange
one reached the destination over here so
what's actually going to happen with
this orange one this part of the drawing
is is not going to happen right
because once they do intersect over here
the orange one is going to travel at the
same speed as the blue one because it
can't pass the blue one right on the
drawing we showed that the orange one
passed the blue one but that's that's
impossible in the context of this
problem right so a better uh drawing for
the orange one would have been something
like this
right like it starts at a high slope but
then it slows down and just to finish up
the drawing so this other one five two
it starts at position five it has a
slope of two so by the time it reaches
the destination it'll be at 2.5 which is
about over here i think so let's just
draw a continuous line and even though
it's kind of hard to draw a straight
line here but you can see again these
intersected as well right so that must
mean since all three of them intersected
that must mean that we're gonna have a
single car fleet right and that's pretty
obvious when you look at a drawing and
actually when we look closer at the
drawing we see that the orange one
intersected with the green one before it
intersects with the blue one so actually
when the orange one intersects here it's
actually going to be traveling at the
same rate as the uh green one
and you can continue with this drawing
if it kind of gives you a good intuition
of the problem i just wanted to kind of
show you like where i'm coming from with
this problem and that i'm not just
immediately jumping to the solution but
knowing kind of this idea we can
kind of get into the solution to this
problem and we can actually do it in
linear time so now you can see that i've
drawn the cars and their positions in
sorted order and that makes sense right
wouldn't we want to go through the cars
in sorted order because of course we
know that they can't like the relative
order of the cars is never gonna change
so it makes sense to go through them in
sorted order now for any two given cars
such as these two how do we know if
they're gonna intersect or you know
they're gonna collide and become a
single car fleet before they reach the
destination position well basically by
the drawing i showed you earlier if
these two intersect each other right so
what we could do is actually calculate
the intersection point of these two if
we really wanted to but there's a
slightly easier way we can just
calculate what time is this car going to
reach the destination and what time is
this car going to reach the destination
if this car reaches the destination
before or at the same time as this one
that must mean that they became a car
fleet right they became a car fleet
somewhere in the middle somewhere in
here so since this one is moving at one
mile per hour and this one is moving at
two miles per hour or whatever you know
whatever unit of speed or something that
they gave us we can calculate what time
they're going to reach the destination
we can do it pretty easily right we can
just take the distance difference for
you know i'm gonna do the green one
first we can take 10 minus seven right
that's the distance that we need to
travel three units of distance and
divide that by the speed in this case
one so this is going to reach the
destination at time equals 3. we can do
the same thing for this one so 10 minus
5 divided by 2 that's going to be 2.5 so
this is going to reach the destination
at time
2.5 so that must mean that they are
going to collide so we know they're
going to be one car fleet so technically
we can kind of just like delete one of
these right
and just not consider it anymore but
which one of these two are we going to
remove right like
okay let's say i remove one and then you
know i start comparing the remainder of
the list that's on the left side well
i'll tell you right now we're always
gonna keep the one that comes ahead
because if these collided they're gonna
end up being reduced down to the speed
of the one that's ahead right so this is
gonna start traveling at one instead of
two right that's gonna be the new speed
so if we want to know if these two
intersect it's going to be harder to
calculate because this one is going to
have two different speeds initially it's
going to be 2 but at some portion it's
going to change to 1. so it's easier if
we
keep this one because this one is always
going to be traveling at speed one and
one more thing we're actually we're not
going to go from left to right we're
going to go from right to left when we
do this operation and the reason is
pretty much the same because if we
started at the beginning and then we
were checking okay do does this one
collide with the blue one well we don't
even know what speed the blue one is
going to be traveling throughout the
whole thing we can't just assume it's
traveling at speed two the entire time
because it could collide with somebody
else and slow down that's why it's
better to start from the right and then
iterate through this in reverse order
okay now and just to complete the
example so we know that this is going to
end up colliding with this one so we can
just assume that this car is a single
car fleet we have one more car over here
and it's traveling at speed three so now
we wanna know is this one going to
collide with this one we already know
what time this is gonna reach the
destination let's calculate the time
this is gonna reach the destination so
we can do 10 minus three so that's seven
divided by three that's going to be two
point something right let's just say two
point i think it's 2.3 or something but
it's not too important but we know that
this uh since it has a smaller time than
the one ahead of it then they are going
to collide and remember which one of
them are we gonna delete we are gonna
delete
this one because it's the one that's
behind okay so before we get into the
code just to mention the overall time
complexity of this portion of the
algorithm where we're actually going
through the cars is big o of n but of
course we know we actually have to sort
the input based on the position so
that's going to make the overall time
complexity end up being n log n uh and
the extra space is just going to be big
o of n
because we're going to be creating a
separate array but we're also going to
be using a stack just to give you a
preview of how we're going to be doing
this so so just to let you know
initially our stack is going to be empty
we're going to go through this in
reverse order so first car we're going
to go ahead and add it to the stack okay
next car we're going to go ahead and
take this and then add it to the top of
the stack but then we're going to
compare
this car with the other car that's
adjacent to it on the stack right both
of these are going to be on the stack if
they collide with each other which we
can calculate pretty easily then we're
going to remove the one that's on the
top of the stack
this one is the one that's on the top of
the stack so this is the one we're going
to pop from the stack and that's how
we're going to do the algorithm so you
know assuming we pop this from the stack
but then we add this one and and then we
end up popping this one as well what
we're going to end up returning is the
number of car fleets that actually exist
at the end of the entire algorithm which
we can get easily because we can just
take the length of our stack and that'll
tell us how many car fleets we actually
have and it's just going to be a single
one in this example problem so now let's
get into the code okay now let's write
the code i love problems like these
where we can spend most of our time
actually explaining it and talking about
it and then the code becomes easy the
first thing i'm going to do is just kind
of create an array of pairs uh in python
it's pretty easy to do i'm just going to
iterate through both of the position and
speed array simultaneously i can do that
with zip but you can you know instead of
using an array of pairs you can also
just uh have like a hash map or
something and then just sort the
positions if you want i'm doing it this
way because it's easiest but you can do
it how you'd like this is i think called
list comprehension in python if you want
to google it we're just creating an
array of pairs but next we don't want to
forget to actually sort that array of
pairs so actually
when we go ahead and iterate through the
array of pairs p
position and speed in
sorted pair and so we can iterate
through this sorted but we also want to
make sure we iterate through it in
reverse order in python that's pretty
easy to do just like this so just to
clarify what we're doing is reverse
sorted order and we need one more
data structure just our stack which will
tell us how many car fleets we have at
the end okay so we're going through
every single car remember when we get to
a car we want to know what time is it
going to reach the destination we can
get that easily just by taking target
minus the position of this car and then
dividing that by the speed in python
this is decimal division and that's very
important because we know the time could
be a decimal we don't want to make an
integer of it we don't want to make an
integer division by adding two slashes
so we're going to take this time and
we're going to go ahead and append it to
our stack
and once we've appended it to our stack
whoops there's a little typo we want to
know does it overlap with the other one
at the top of our stack so first we want
to make sure that our stack has at least
two elements in it because if it just
has one element just one car then we
don't really need to do anything
but if it has at least two cars it could
be possible that we have a collision so
if the
the time that the top of our stack at
index negative one that's how you can
get to the top of the stack in python if
it reaches the destination before the
one that's ahead of it at index negative
two like if the time of it is less than
the next one that must mean they collide
that must mean we have to pop from the
stop of the stack and by doing that
we're decreasing the number of car
fleets if we don't pop then we leave it
as it is and in case i didn't explain
this earlier you might be wondering why
is this an if statement rather than a
while loop and let me explain that for a
second suppose that this is our stack
right we have three elements so and when
we get to this one right and we find
that okay this collides with this one
right so then what are we gonna do we're
just gonna pop this from our stack right
but then you might be thinking okay well
what if this one collides with this one
right then we have to also remove this
one don't we but you're you might be
forgetting that we already probably
checked that condition because we're
traversing this in reverse order right
before we even get to this car over here
we're gonna check okay does this collide
with anybody nope okay does this collide
with this guy
nope and then we get to this one and we
find yes this one actually does collide
with this guy but that's okay because
just because it collides with this it'll
never collide with the next one because
once it does collide with the blue one
these two will be traveling at the same
speed and we determined that this won't
collide with that so it's impossible for
this to collide with this one so that's
why we're doing it this way and that's
actually all we have to do after we're
done with that we can just go ahead and
return the length of the stack and let's
run this to make sure that it works and
as you can see on the left it does work
and it's relatively efficient so i
really hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it really
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel if you would
like and hopefully i'll see you pretty
soon thanks for watching